I copied and pasted into the next you
cuz they had a little bit of a drawing
so I thought better than me drawing it
myself so in problem number 13 it says I
cut it off a little bit what is the
volume of the figure below well the
volume is just the width times the
height times the depth so the volume is
just going to be you could say volume is
going to be the width is X plus 4 times
X plus 1 times X plus 6 all right
X plus 4 times X plus 1 we can do this
in our head but I always well let's
justwell I always find it easier to do
it this way X plus 4 times X plus 1 1
times 4 is 4 1 times X is X and then you
have the x place x times 4 is 4x x times
X is x squared
fair enough so that equals x squared
plus 5 X plus 4 and now we have to
multiply that times X plus 6 right we
did X plus 4 and X plus 1 and this was a
6x plus 6 that's this side so now we
multiply this times X plus 6 6 times 4
is 24
6 times 5x is 30x 6 times x squared is
6x squared
I hope you can read what I'm writing
scroll down a little bit now we do the
XS play side in a different color
because I think I'm going to run out of
so x times 4 is 4x x times 5x is 5 x
squared 5x squared x times x squared is
X to the 3rd to run into the white area
so this is X to the 3rd with 6 plus 5
plus 11x squared plus 30x no no sorry 30
plus 4 plus 30 4 X plus 24 so X to the
3rd all of these choices are X to the
3rd plus 11x squared so it's either B or
D plus 34 X that's that one plus 34 X
plus 24 so the choice is B next problem
the next problem all right
8a to the third plus C to the third
which of these choices so that's
interesting this is not a trivial thing
to just factor you know you just have to
we'll have to do some intuition here
let's think about it in order to have a
positive number for the eighth term
every time we're multiplying it well
every time we're multiplying we have to
have positives so this is 2a times 2a
times 2a that would get us to 8a to the
3rd but there's something interesting
about choice a why why I already feel
like canceling out choice a choice a is
essentially 2a plus C to the third power
right choice a is 2a plus C to the third
power and every time you multiply this
out every time you multiply 2a plus C
times itself you're going to add more
terms no terms are going to cancel out I
mean if you were to square this you're
going to get you know just to show you
you get 4a squared plus 4ac plus C
squared and then to get the third power
you'd multiply that times 2a plus C so
you're gonna get this thing with you're
actually going to get four terms so this
is that to a choice a is definitely not
the case in order for one of these to
simplify to this we're gonna have to
have some positive and negatives there
that cancel out turning does you expand
these polynomials so let's look at the
other choices see if they make any sense
to a times and I like looking at at the
a terms and what generates the C cubed
terms and maybe we can cancel out some
things 2a times 4a squared
yeah that's 8a to the 3rd but minus C
times C squared that's minus C to the
third right so when I don't even have to
worry about multiplying this whole thing
out I know because the C 3rd the C cubed
term is going to come only from this
term multiplied by this term right
there'll be other terms that hopefully
will cancel out but we know that choice
B cannot be the choice cuz minus C times
C squared is minus C to the third and
this is a plus right here so we know B
can't be the right answer let's see
choice C I can use the same logic we
have a minus C and we have a plus C and
we have a plus C here we would have to
have 2 plus C's in order for this to
work so this can't be
sir so just by deductive reasoning I can
say it's probably choice D but I'm gonna
prove it to you since we're here to
learn not to just answer things
correctly so if I were to multiply those
two numbers I have 4a squared minus 2ac
plus C squared and I'm multiplying that
times two a plus C two a plus C so I'm
gonna mix up all of the terms a little
bit but you will get the idea so the
important thing when you're multiplying
you could do this in your head is that
you multiply each of these terms times
each of those so C times all of that
Plus this times all of that so C times
all of that is C times C squared I'm not
doing it the right place notation like I
did last time because it gets a little
more confusing now but C times C squared
is C to the third C the third C times
minus 2ac is minus 2a C squared right C
times 4a squared is 4a squared C and
then now we can do this one to a times C
squared that is the same thing as I'm
going to put it in this place because it
turns into AC squared right AC squared
and I have a 2 so 2 a times C squared is
2 AC squared 2 a times minus 2 AC that's
so you get a minus 4 a squared C so it's
minus 4a squared see this is a plus here
and then 2a times 4a squared is 8 a to
the third and luckily enough let's see
they get an 8 a to the third 8 a to the
third this cancels out this cancels out
and you get plus C to the third so we
were right by doing our deductive
reasoning that choice D was the answer
next problem let me have run out of
space run out of space and let me see
what the next problem even is okay
actually where was I
okay I see okay problem 15 the total
area of a rectangle is 4 X to the 4th
minus 9y squared which factors could
represent the length times the width
okay so essentially there's you're
saying the length times the width is
going to be equal to the area which is 4
X to the 4th minus 9y squared so the
some degree we have to factor this into
multiple expressions and and the first
thing you should always look at when you
have to extract or any type of an
expression especially if there's only
two terms in the expression does it fit
the form a squared minus B squared
because if it does you can factor this
into a plus B times a minus B and if you
don't trust that these equal each other
I've made multiple videos about it but
just multiply them a plus B times a
minus B is equal to a squared minus B
squared and luckily this fits that
format right if a let's see if if a
squared was equal to a squared is equal
to 4x to the fourth then what's a a
would be equal to 2x squared right and
if B squared if B squared is equal to 9
Y squared then B is equal to the square
root of that which is 3y alright and so
this definitely is equal to a squared
minus B squared so this expression right
here can be factored into a plus B times
a minus B so a plus B is 2x squared plus
3y times a minus B 2x squared minus 3y
let's see which choice is that 2x
squared plus 3y okay this was the order
choice a says 2x squared minus 3y times
2 x squared plus 3y which is the same
thing you can switch orders when you're
multiplying so the answer is a next
problem problem 16 I'll switch colors
arbitrarily problem 16 which product of
factors is equivalent to
let me let me copy and paste this cuz
this is this is an interesting so let me
copy and paste this problem
okay I've copied it and now let me let
me paste it here okay which product of
factors is equivalent to that thing over
there so let's let's simplify that
that's my first impulse oh no no we
don't even have to simplify it we don't
even have to simplify it this fits our
same pattern right if we can fit the
pattern a squared minus B squared so
look at this thing this has X plus 1
squared minus y squared so if we said
that a is equal to X plus 1 and B is
equal to Y then we fit the pattern right
this is a squared minus B squared so
then this thing can just factor into a
plus B times a minus B right so what's a
plus B it's X plus 1 plus y all right
that's a plus B and then a minus B is X
plus 1 minus y and that is choice D that
problem was easier than I thought it was
going to be choice D right there right
there all right and I'm out of time
again I'll see you in the next video